hi everyone this is Kim from the test
website calm today we're going to be
going over a pretty cool game it called
the airsoft game it derives from the
bishop opening so pawn to e4 pawn e5 and
then Bishop to c4 and I like this
because a lot of players is black they
don't know how to respond and after
Knight to f6 instead of playing your
common nice f3 Knight to c3 White's
going to go with herself game it and
that's pawn to d4 now as far as
theoretical gambits go i do recognize
this is probably not as sound as the
queen's game at some of the other more
popular ones even king's gambit i prefer
to this but i still think a lot of
players is black they're just not
prepared to how to really defend against
this correctly and white has some really
aggressive moves so that's what we're
going to be going over today black kind
of has a few options he could take with
his pawn here on d4 the main line he
could also take with his knight here on
a for much worse but he could actually
do that so we're going to first start
off with he does take care on e4 since
this is a mistake I want to make sure
everyone's aware of how to make sure
that you can take advantage of your
mistakes from your opponent always going
to be taking the pawn here on e5 this
opens up the door for the Queen to get
involved into the board I do have a very
central pawn here on e5 they can kind of
take some of the squares away if your
opponent as they try to even move their
knight back here to d6 or f6 so just
really aggressive square also opens up
the door for the Queen to come up here
to d5 start to attack this f7 square can
always have a sacrifice here on f7 with
the bishop that's kind of why you're
playing that the bishop here to c4 in
the first place
so from here if black continues to play
bad moves which are not always going to
see bad moves but you could see it
sometimes 96 very bad moves in this
particular case you just play pawn or
Bishop takes here on f7 after the King
comes down takes on f7 then cling up
here to d5 and then after the King moves
the Queen is going to come back here
take that material on e4 now all of a
sudden hey White's looking pretty good
he got that material back oh and by the
way this King it can no longer castle
this is going to be a very very good
game from wife now
if we change it up a little bit and said
okay instead of that nice coming here to
c6 let's say you try to play pawn to d6
okay Queen up here to d5 attacking both
night here on e4 also attacking
checkmate up here on f7 really the only
good move for black here if he doesn't
play this it should be pretty intuitive
as far as where to go but just bring the
knight back here to g5 it's no longer
being attacked and also protecting the
pawn here on f7 pawn is just going to
take on d6 and then really you're going
to have to play Knight over here to e6
because that's you know Bishop to d6
Bishop up here g5 Queen really can't
come down because Queen up here to f7
things get very tricky so instead of
this ship taking or even the queen
taking because then you just take this
material with your Bishop all things are
bad you're going to play this Knight to
e6 kind of blocking off the Queen coming
here to f7 but then you can do a couple
things you could first take with your
pawn if you wanted to there could be
some exchange black may decide I just
don't want to have to deal with a lot of
the attack so the Queen's exchange in
the middle of the board after the
Knights exchange back I'll besides nice
to see three mission abort I think this
is going to be pretty good eventually
play Bishop here to e3 castle on the
Queen side and have a really strong
attack on board so I think this is going
to be good but if you don't want to
start to exchange off your Queens on
board yeah you could play a little bit
differently after the night up here to
e6 and then the movie could you play is
Knight to c3 that just says okay this is
this is fine I like the board stay right
here I've Center control of the board
I'm not really looking to exchange a lot
of material off and said I'll just
continue to develop my pieces things
going to be good could see Bishop takes
on d6 given that material back Bishop to
e3 getting ready to castle on the Queen
side really start to attack your
opponent look at all the material that
white has on board it's going to be very
very fun which is why you generally play
gamuts from here so castle on the King
side and castle on the Queen side if we
come back to this position we might say
the black Bishop comes out here to c5
trying to counter-attack in the center
of the board get pieces evolved
so you can castle on the Kings side to
get this rook over here on f8 to protect
this pawn here on f7 from here you have
a couple options the first woman to
bring the Queen up here to d5
threatening mate on f7 until your going
to gobble up material here on e4 or you
could just say I'm going to go ahead and
take with my bishop or take the pawn
here on f7 and then after we have the
exchange then you have the Queen comes
up here to d5 and then you're going to
take that material I think it's probably
a little stronger to play the Queen up
here to d5 I'm just never going to play
it I will kind of go through the
scenarios of why that is so let's say
you play queen up here - to d5 we are
threatening mate here so there's a
couple ways to kind of stop this one of
them would be for the black queen to
come down here to h4 this does allow if
the pawn falls here on f7 for the King
to come here to DA so there's a little
breathing room also starts to attack
white with the threat of queen taking
here on f2 and so from here we could see
pawn to g3 stopping the attack Bishop
down on f2 if wants to give up some
material King to f1 white loses the
ability to castle Queen to g4 once to
make sure he's no longer attacked not up
here to d2 since there is starting to be
a strong attack on board Knight takes
this should take Bishop takes you're on
g1 and then the Queen out can finally
come up here to f7 but then the King to
d8 and then rook takes here on a g1 this
is all fine if you like this position
you may decide to go ahead and play that
Queen to d5 early on I think it's a
little bit easier if you like the
ability to castle have a little more
king safety it's going to be fine just
as well to play Bishop takes on f7 after
the King takes here then clean up here
to d5 and then King f8 Queen takes on e4
I mean this is great you still have the
option knight here to f3 castle on the
King side if you really wanted to play
you know Bishop get involved into the
board Knight up here to c3 castle on the
Queen side and just really throw
everything at your opponent on the King
side because your opponent's king right
now can
longer Cassel a really really expose
it's going to be very difficult he's
going to have to play no pawn to d6 try
to block the open things up get its
light squared Bishop bring his knight
over and get it involved into the game
all in all really good positions I think
is a little bit easier so definitely you
can try this on board another move that
you could see is Queen to h4 it is being
protector for this night here on e4 I
would just go ahead and take again on f7
that's kind of a theme that's if you're
familiar that's why you're playing this
bishops opening with Bishop here on c4
always that constant threat of going
here to f7 forcing your opponent to take
you or just give up material all in all
it's going to be a bad spot for black
here so after the King takes on f7 then
g3 forcing the Queen to move you know he
has a few variations he could just
decide to bring his queen back here to
e7 can't bring it here to g5 or f6
because they'll just died to the bishop
or the paneer and then queen up here to
d5 and then after the King moves then
the Knights going to fall that's one
option he could also try to be super
creative and play Bishop to b4 checked
and then pawn to c3 eventually the
Queen's going to have to move because
the Queen and the bishop are being
attacked so once the Queen does move
Queen up here to d5 and then you're
going to gobble up material it could be
you know in this particular piff your
blacks but all in all it's going to be a
pretty good position so that was what
happens if the knight takes on e4 that's
not going to be the most common it's
definitely the worst way for blacks to
continue the most common way is going to
play pawn takes on d4 and then from here
we're going to play Knight to f3 it's a
little tricky if you play pawn to e5
first so nice to f3 and this is where
we're going to spend more of our time
looking at some of the lines as far as
how your opponent's going to continue
now one option he has is to accept this
game at on e4 he could say there's a
pawn material that I want to capture so
I'm gonna go ahead and take dot on e4
it's kind of a bad setup for black if
you know Queen takes here on d4 yes
black is up upon the
but if you look at all of the
centerpieces right here getting ready to
castle on the kingside really starting
to put pressure on this knight on e4 so
he's going to have to be moving dancing
around the board that's not that great
so often I think this is a pretty easy
game for whites to kind of overwhelm his
opponents nice to f6 is probably the
most common move that you'll see is kind
of safest you can just continue Knight
to c3 knight c6 Queen down here to d3
does gain a little bit of tempo but then
you can bring your bishop out start to
pin down the night if you want to you
can cast on the queenside castle on the
King side lots of different option
options and since the sin of the board
is open you can really bring your books
here to d1 e1 and really start to
overwhelm your opponent if you do see
something a little bit crazier mostly
because your opponent just may not know
how to continue you could see nice to
see five the bishop is defending this
right here not the best move from black
but you could see it just continued
castle on the King side now nice to see
six same kind of thing but you could
have an in-between move right now rook
to e1 check you can see Knight back here
to e6
then the Queen falls back to a d3
getting ready to get the bishop
involvement of the game nice to see
three very easy to continue you it's
going to be tough for whites to kind of
mess this up on board one of the things
that you'll see pretty frequently is
Knight to c6 it develops a minor piece
from your opponent gets involved into
the center of the board protecting this
pawn here on d4 which is under attack
from this Queen so I see this more often
than not from here going to continue
with pawn to e5 and this is a pseudo
variation of the Scotch game but not all
the nicer involved into the game as much
but if you watch the Scotch
gambit video I created you'll see this
is one of the the lines that I cover
towards the end of that video so
definitely check that out if you haven't
seen it from here there's there's three
lines that you'll see one of them is
Knight to g4 it's no longer being
attacked and all of a sudden there's two
nice attacking this pawn right here
doesn't matter if you play g4 or efore
kind of go over theirs first thing
you're going to do is castle on the King
set because it actually is still
protected even though you have one night
here on f3 it's it's still being
protected by even this rook here on f1
meaning that if tonight takes on e5
you have the knight capture after the
Knight takes rook here to e1 pinning
down this knife if he tries to defend
that with me pawn to d6 and all of a
sudden pawn to f4 and the nice force to
move or force to fall because you can't
move he is being pinned down so that's
how you approach it if they played that
Knight to g4 if instead they played
Knight to e4 which is fine then you're
just going to castle on the King side as
well
they could play Bishop here to e7 that's
fine just continue you still have this
pawn on e5 and a particular case he
hasn't even tried to capture that so you
still have that the center goodness that
you were going for you can even you know
play pawn to c3 recapture with your
knight some people like to give up an
extra pawn so they have you know nothing
to worry about as far as their opponent
spawns and then sharing the board
definitely strategy I like to employ
myself the last variation you may see in
this position is pawn down here to d5
trying to break up the center of the
board and says hey if you're gonna
attack my knight I'm gonna go and tack
your Bishop it's not worth losing the
bishop in the spots go and just play
Bishop here to b5 and then Knight down
here to e5 probably the best
continuation since a pawn here on d5 is
a great little outpost for this nice on
e4 were before we could kind of kick it
around there was no defense for that
knife Knight takes on d4 Bishop down to
c5 does need his King to have King side
safety so allowing for the bishop to
come out at axis here in the board
castle on the King side is exactly what
black wants to do castle on the Kings
side and then from here you know it's
going to be a pretty solid game which we
could see he doesn't have to play that
Bishop to c5 he could play Bishop to d7
and then we just could see some
exchanges off board you know Bishop
takes on c6 we could see the pawn
recapture here on c6 and then you know
castle on the King side if we want to
this is going to be you know pretty
solid there's double pawns here on the C
file
you always have this pawn you can start
to attack back here on t7 since you have
the dark square Bishop so this is going
to be fine for for white so just keep
this in mind if they do play that d5 you
still going to have a pretty good game
the last line that you could see from
black is Bishop to b4 check very easy
response pawn here to c3 they're usually
just going to take with their pawn on c3
and then you have two options you can
take with your pond you're going to
Castle if you're playing the earth
sobbed and it which means you're playing
game it you want to be super aggressive
you're going to have to cap on the King
side I think it's odd to do anything
else because you kind of want your
opponent to play this pawn takes on b2
bishop recapture zombie to sort of that
Danish gambit where I have all my
bishops
lining up on your Kings side you don't
have a lot of defense over here just try
to overwhelm your opponent
I definitely think that's worth giving
up a pawn for but if you don't want to
be that crazy and you want to play a
little bit more conservative you can
just take back with your pawn so you
know pawn takes here on c3 or even if
you were to castle just so you're aware
they may not take with their pawn they
could decide to go ahead and castle then
okay sure
pawn just takes here on c3 but if you
decide yeah I don't even want to give
them an opportunity you could just take
with your pawn here since the nice
protecting it on b1 they could do a few
things they could decide to play pawn
down here to d5 okay just go ahead and
take that material don't don't think
it's too tricky or anything Bishop back
here to d6 castle on the Kings side
that's going to be fine
it's instead they play Bishop to e7
sometimes it if a player is not familiar
with how to play correctly they'll just
retreat back to not to were squared
which would be f8 but just to e7 it's a
safe square they can castle on the King
side but a bt7
just go ahead and play pawn to e5 as
we've seen before in this opening force
the knight to move there's no great
squares you have your Knight to e4 and
then Queen up here to d5 we've kind of
seen how that's really bad for black if
he tries to come over here to g4
then just pawn to h3 just
I'm still protected by the night here on
f3 so all in all just going to end up
wasting movies you're going to get two
really bad spotty can't come here to f6
it comes back here to h6 all of its and
you just take with your bishop
this is a pretty bad setup for black on
board and then last one you could see if
we come back the bishop may decide to
come to c5 still in the serve the board
trying to attack things but a pawn to e5
do not let up at all has a few options
from here nice to g4 as we've kinda
already talked about but this is kind of
one of those nice positions where you
have a discovered attack of one to
sacrifice the bishop takes on f7 after
the King takes then you have the ability
to just go ahead and play Knight to g5
the bishop is protecting this knife and
you have a discovered attack on the
night here on a g4 so that's going to be
extremely good if instead they decide
okay you're attacking my knight right
here I'm going to go ahead and play pawn
to d5 attack your bishop okay well let's
go ahead and exchange I think this is
completely fine let's go to exchange off
Queens you can no longer castle it's not
as needed if the Queen's are off the
board
but pawn takes on g7 a rook here to g8
and then a bishop here to h6
all no I think is a pretty good spot for
white so that is an introduction to the
earth saw gambit and a lot of the lines
that you could see so hopefully you
enjoy that especially if you like the
the pawn to e4 getting into the bishops
game a Bishop to c4 always an aggressive
lon so check it out
test out suit you guys think if you have
any other video requests I got a lot of
requests for this video specifically
feel free to email me the chess website
at gmail.com I'll make sure I add that
to the queue and get that video created
but thanks everyone for watching I'll
see you in the next video